i gotta i gotta pull up this story uh
let's talk about the the collapses aside
here we go from yahoo news starbucks is
closing 16 stores across los angeles
portland seattle and other cities due to
a high frequency of challenging
incidents
what they mean is employees were being
attacked people were doing drugs in the
bathroom and let me just say this is one
of the most epic get woke go brokes
because four years ago starbucks got
attacked by a bunch of woke activists
and announced our bathrooms are now open
and everyone said dude your bathroom's
open to the public it's going to be a
disaster of drug use this is a problem
and they're nasty and it's so bad last
month starbucks said we may have to
close our bathrooms but that would have
drawn the ire of the far left activists
so what did they do shut the whole store
down we're done yeah
yeah i mean if you go into a starbucks
bathroom in a city they are disgusting
their coffee is disgusting i can't
believe people drink it it tastes like
burgers
yes but the starbucks nitro cold
i've never gotten to that point i do a
french press of my own stuff every day
and i don't drink that burnt crap unless
i'm in an airport cracked out like oh my
god cold brew though
i haven't tried it i if i try it and
you've lied to me for breakfast i have a
can uh is all i have is a can of well i
have more but so when i wake up i have a
can of nitro cold brew with heavy cream
and it's like a chocolate milkshake
almost
butter powder wait how many calories is
in that there's like 10 calories in the
cold brew and then i think like 80 in
the cream 50 per tablespoon of heavy
whipping cream 50 per tablespoon okay so
maybe 100 about 100 that is not worth
those calories i like cupcakes
if i'm gonna eat all that crap i'm gonna
have a cupcake
i
have lost 30 pounds
with your coffee breakfast with my well
i do have eggs so i'll have coffee and
then i record so after i record my first
segment i usually have like eggs and
bacon or something
but i cut out all the cupcakes and all
of that evil dispelling a myth the
calories aren't actually in the food a
calorie is a measurement of heat that's
produced when your body breaks the food
apart so you're actually producing the
calories i stopped eating cups cakes and
stuff like that when i ran out of time
to do a lot of baking i used to do a lot
of baking which i kind of missed doing i
was making these like tall like eight
layer cakes but many like really like
what i do like really tall like top hats
good for you right i make layers they're
so good and i have these like little
tiny pants they're like this we're women
and once a month we need cupcakes and
sugar because there's a difference
and if we don't have it you'll die so
all men out there give us
sugar you need like a steak yeah
it all depends
you need the steak during you need the
chocolate yeah
chocolate or the sugar because
chocolate's really good for you i love
chocolate cacao without sugar just pure
bitter it tastes like coffee beans kind
of i like just i always have chocolate
in my handbag you can taste the iron in
it i'm a super health nut so clearly i'm
not like sitting around eating sugar all
day like all i do is work out and count
calories so when i do
do something bad like my husband and i
will eat like three pizza and go get a
huge thing of krispy kreme and just eat
the whole box i love how it's like
society is collapsing and starbucks is
shutting down but their coffee is bad
anyway yeah yeah it tastes like burnt
butthole i can't believe i don't know
i do think that it's uh
my first job was an ice cream
oh well i was when i was starting mines
the social network we were uh we would
work in i'd go to a starbucks oh i see
you'd do that no i just i scooped ice
cream i don't know i i would i do think
that it's very disturbing to see the
infrastructure that was created with the
with the wealth that our culture had
just completely collapsed so here's my
my idea which man i want to do all these
awesome things i just need people who
can help do them uh i i just buy
starbucks they sacrificed the well-being
of their employees to appease the woke
mob they knew it was going to make their
stores more dangerous they knew that it
was going to welcome in people to do
drugs and be belligerent and violent
they didn't care and now they have to
shut down 16 stores disrupting all of
these employees because they don't care
now some people have said oh but they
pay well and think okay fine you know
what i want to do i talked about before
i want to open a coffee shop right next
to a starbucks and i want to do the
starbucks what starbucks is accused of
doing other shops subsidize everything
make it so cheap that starbucks can't
afford to be open and then tell those
employees come work for us and we'll pay
you better and we'll treat it like a
co-op
we won't play this garbage where we let
weirdos in the bathroom while you're
working you'll be in charge and here's
my favorite part if you are working at
my coffee shop when we open it and a
customer is being rude feel free to cook
them out and tell them never to come
back i don't play the stupid game where
the customer is always right if they're
being belligerent to the employees who
are making the food
is that true at starbucks you're not
allowed to kick people out if they suck
i don't know if starbucks does that the
idea is that the customer is always
right and most of these big corporate
stores are like just be demure and
apologize no
no it's it's it's it's your store you're
trying to do people a favor you're
providing a service we're all equals
here if someone's giving you the
business you say look just have a nice
day you can go um i want a place where
the employees are not going to be
stepped all over for the corporate
agenda it's also really not fair to have
the because employees like at starbucks
and whatever you have to clean the
bathroom like everyone's sort of on a
shift to clean the bathroom exactly and
it's so nasty to do that like i used to
work at an obon pain a million years ago
and we always had to switch off who was
cleaning the bathroom women's bathrooms
are the worst it was just it was it was
not it was just one bathroom right and
like random people would come in there
and they would defecate all over the
place and we would have to clean it up
and that's just really unhealthy on the
wall sometimes oh yeah i worked at acme
like my stomach is turning right now
like just remembering the experience
just having to clean that bathroom after
like
i'm sorry random
four years old and everything poop makes
me laugh can i just gross it it was so
gross i just want to ask this question
uh i want to make this point actually
you guys up at the shopping cart test no
oh yeah i love it it's this idea that
the shopping cart is the ultimate test
of like whether a person can function in
society
returning the shopping cart to the cart
corral
is a minor task
minor inconvenience it has no reward you
know it's the right thing to do you
should do it
most people don't most people don't yeah
they just well it depends on where
you're at i suppose so you know where i
was in where i lived in uh the philly
suburbs you'd go to the walmart and it's
just carts everywhere and so someone
comes out and people just like they put
the cart to the side and i'm like just
return the car it takes five seconds
it's the right thing to do but then you
gotta think about these bathrooms
when when you mention people getting on
the wall and stuff yeah what the heck
i've seen that think about
there's a video there's a video of a guy
going in an elevator
and he pisses on the elevator buttons
causing a malfunction and then he panics
and then i'm just like what is wrong
with people that they're like i'm going
to piss on an elevator button freaking
mark in their territories
someone goes into a bathroom like no one
can see me now i'll just ruin someone's
day but is that like they they have ibs
the irritable bowel syndrome and they
can't handle it they're like ah they
can't make it to the toilet and it flies
out it's because they're hovercrafting
like a woman
sit on it they don't want to sit on it
but if you do the squat thing right and
you're not going to sit on the public
toilet like how hard is it to just clean
up after yourself like why don't people
do that but then you're just cleaning up
urine and someone's like oh look at this
clean seat and then they sit in your pee
because you think you've done some
service to society no there's a video
clean up after a self-cleaning
the whole toilet
moves like it spins around there's like
two toys and spins around and on the
other side it's like got scrubbers and a
spray in it
and then it's like which goes in in
france in spain
in europe they have like public urinals
i think they're like these uh uh
it's it's uh elevated off the ground so
you can see feet and then it's like a
spiral and you walk to the middle of the
spiral and there's a hole in the ground
you piss into and they did that because
homeless people and drunks were just
peeing everywhere interesting so they
made these weird little things i think
they're in europe they might be i think
i think they might have those in like
seattle maybe
i think in india you have to pay to use
the public toilet everywhere in europe
i'm glad you brought up the guy peeing
on the elevator buttons cause like i
love michael malus but he believes
people can govern themselves
i doubts
okay malice people will pee on the
elevator buttons and get themselves
stuck in the elevators i think he's so
smart he forgets that most everyone else
is a [ __ ]
or just not even alice is a great friend
and i'm a big fan he's a very smart guy
yeah but he needs rules he often says
that uh how could anyone be pessimistic
when you see how dumb these people are
and my response to that is yes they're
dumb but many dumb people can be
dangerous like a zombie horde you know
what i mean yeah or stampede right or
twitter
and dumb people can get frustrated
easier when they don't understand they
can tend towards frustration which leads
towards anger and then they can become
very very malicious and dangerous yeah
this is what we're seeing right now so
here's what i think is happening
strong-willed people inquisitive people
and smart people they they know what's
happening in the world they turn on the
news and they're like is that true and
they check and they go oh that wasn't
true just smell like lied then you have
people who are just dumb as a box of
rocks going like whoa jesse smilet and
they go on tv and they're like this is
not a debate what happened to jesse
smilet is so wrong and then the host
goes like i agree and this is like these
people are as dumb as dumb kids wait a
minute was that the dead named person
that was the daddy i don't know what
you're talking about the dead named
person i was making a random vague
analogy no you awoken a demon in my
brain of memory
i'm like wait the artist is formerly
known as prince yes that's his song
that's what we're going to come when i
was going on his page concerts i would
watch the people play and then people
would be like
i'm like what are they screaming and
like everyone's clapping to get i'm like
what is this like call this this weird
a this this creature that's being formed
in the sea of humans like i don't i
would just like watch and like even if i
loved it i wasn't going to be like
you know like
that's been with us the whole time i
mean that's dionysian that's like you
know ancient rites of sensory overload
you know we have that you know i i
i don't know i don't see anything wrong
with that with like enjoying that to an
extent and
um and getting all crazy like that is
the mindless clap because if you do that
at a concert ideally you're not doing
that ever you know in your accounting
department people are animals i wonder
if those are the people that are like
just on autopilot that like what are you
they're having a great time like maybe
they're having a great time and really
enjoying it but i was also having a
great time and enjoying the music right
i just don't scream about it yeah but
that's just but it depends on what it
gets everyone's a little different like
i can't load my oven without my husband
coming up behind me and i'm like are you
serious absolutely because he's an
animal
so it depends there's something for you
ian that will just awaken this primitive
beast and you'll be like
yeah like i wouldn't
i don't know i wouldn't i wouldn't judge
that i've seen ian do the whole night
clapping when we showed him a sheet of
graphene his eyes just turned white
tim cass out of context here we go
i get excited but i guess maybe that
said i don't get overly excited i just
don't get over excited i never have yeah
it makes sense so why freak out
wait let's talk about like the catholic
church i bet you a million bucks we can
get you yelling it was similar like a
church congregation watching people clap
and scream was like watching a bunch of
people concert wasn't repeat the show
emcee hammer
this little kid up on stage kept getting
up and dancing in the audience
what was your first what was your first
comment yeah that was your first comment
police amber don't hurt them
my first concert was fleta what was it
called i think it's pronounced what is
that uh i don't know elvis costello
played that oh that's cool yeah mine was
bruce springsteen at the meadowlands oh
nice so are you guys you saying that
people that cheer and scream are not
inherently stupid
than other people because i i look at it
as like a why are you doing that i don't
understand it's their tribal rite of
passage to like scream at local h or
something i don't know
it's like it's tribalism yeah chicago
but that to me indicates like a lack of
intelligence why would you fall for a
call
it's a it's a sensory overload
experience maybe they all have autism so
they don't have the eq to handle it and
they just get overloaded and start
yelling or they like it's like feeling
the spirit of god yeah it's kind of like
that imagine imagine it's just a crazy
trip like i watched the guy i watched
the guy play music and music i can't put
you there that's why i watch the guys i
watch the guys over the weekend so you
clap for him because you want them to
know you appreciate what they're doing
so it's like virtue signaling it's not
virtue signaling it's gratitude if it's
their friends when it's your friend and
even when their stuff sucks you're like
yeah i don't want to distract them i
don't do that to myself like in a
baseball game if they hit the ball and
you go yeah if you scream the people in
the outfield will like shudder and the
ball will go by them so you're a fifth
you're like another player on the team
but i don't that's that's what's
happening screaming at a guy makes it
better or easier for them no you taunt
them like yeah that's doing a sports
game right
this is yeah this has nothing to do with
with the fact that people want people
peeing on elevators i think it does it
doesn't very little i i i see a through
line of people that are mindlessly
walking through life i've been to i've
been to shows where the crowd is like
the venue's full and the opening act
draws no movement and no applause they
play and everyone just stands there and
they're like looking and then the main
band comes out and they're like now
we're gonna play our number one single
called the magic butterfly and i was
like yeah and they're cheating because
they like the song
it's like i don't think blindly just
going like oh we're clapping like
whoever's there i stand and watch
because i like the song it's not like if
you like the song you will scream you're
not the arbiter of morality and emotion
i just i feel like an outsider i felt
like an outsider for a lot of my life
watching people act very strange and
like cults like
what i will say is look
i i've cheered for bands i don't think
there's anything wrong with cheering for
a band having a good time there's a
difference though when you look at mob
mentality and like the summer of love
when people were just running around
smashing windows peacefully for just for
no reason and they don't know why
they're doing it or when you know we
like
there are people who will uh i remember
who we had on the show they were talking
and saying like it was some lefty guy or
was a liberal guy and he was like i told
my friends i was coming on the show and
they were like why tim pools far right
or whatever and they laughed and they
were like do you watch tim pool and they
were like well no but it's like that's
disturbed someone who's like i have no
idea what that is but i'm angry that's
that's everybody though i feel like it's
90 of society anymore it's really sad
so like you're saying earlier you
thought it was like an emotional
experience at watching a band kind of
like yeah i've taken psilocybin and
cried because it felt so real or great
or whatever but yeah the danger is that
it's the guy on stage that's making you
feel like that or you think it is no
it's the song it's the music or the one
playing it the feeling the song the
artistic experience like you're
experiencing this when i watched paul
mccartney play hey jude i had a moment
and i rarely have moments but i was
there having my moment i looked over and
there's like this 80 year old dude like
it's my moment too and we had it
together if paul mccartney had been like
now go right if he'd like forced you to
go do something dangerous would you be
more likely to and why
would people do that why would someone
could you imagine paul mccartney like
that song was called hey dude now
everyone you know burn down police
station
what's up everyone show me your hands
clean hands get your vaccination it's
like that was insane it was insane
you're making fun of a rock concert too
i was at a concert i was at a i was at a
lollapalooza in 1990 kaiser chiefs
that's who they were jane's addiction
playing no that was the previous here
and i went to that one too good but
um smashing pumpkins were playing it was
in west virginia somewhere uh i had
taken a whole bunch of acid and i was
with my friend um and i lost him i don't
know what happened to him i lost my
wallet i lost everything i was tripping
my face off in this crowd 90s experience
yeah i
but i had no idea where anything was i
was really entranced by this music i
loved the smashing pumpkins and then um
billy corgan gets out there and he
starts talking about uh we're generation
we're generation
and i looked up and i was like
wow you just totally ruined my vibe i
was having a great time i'm not nothing
like maybe i'm maybe i've lost my
friends and i've lost my wallet and i've
lost my brain but you're you're a fool
like why are you telling a bunch of kids
who was tripping on [ __ ] billy
horrigan
yeah right not a bunch of kids through
that last words
nothing right but he was having one bad
day and because the call wasn't what
here's the thing my point was my point
is i was having a great time i was
having this whole sensory experience i
was not but despite all of that i was
not swayed by his garbage nonsense but
so like
i heard this and i was like
so if he had said go get vaccinated i
also would have been like what the hell
is wrong you're a strong mind yeah what
about i'm concerned with the people that
pee on elevators
but those people are going to pee on
elevators no matter what you do but if
someone is always going to be an
elevator if someone respects somebody
and that person tells you to pee on the
elevator maybe but there's there's
always going to be those people this is
what is the electric fence this is how
you get social credit systems because
the question is like how do we
effectively govern so the people who pee
on elevator buttons aren't ruining
everything for everyone else and they're
like okay we'll create a system how
about if you pee on elevator buttons you
get dropped down to a lower cast and you
have to earn your way out or whatever to
prove you're not going to pee on
elevator buttons that's why they do it
but the problem there is that it
needlessly punishes people and i think
it curtails meritocracy
you'll get a bunch of
smart people who are arbitrarily held
back in a system like that so you're
actually losing out so i think the
reality is there's risk with freedom
comes risk maybe that's what michael
would say something like that we want
freedom that means sometimes you got to
clean piss off elevator buttons
and that's in that's in genesis that's
in the bible like with freedom it is
it's it's it's you know you know you eat
the apple and then you're gonna have an
elevator button that's right
where do you it's in there like riding a
motorcycle you ask a motorcyclist why do
you do this dangerous thing they're like
i've never felt more free the wind in
their hair and it's super risky people
might not see you know they die all the
time this is what happens when my mom
tells me to wear a bike helmet which i
have never like i hate that does she
still do it today she put it on your
bike yeah i didn't i didn't live with
her until i was 16 so she didn't have a
lot of opportunity when i was kid
but i'll be like mom i i'm not wearing a
bike helmet and you can't wear me make
me she also is always like are you
masking no mom i'm not are you messing
i'm not basking i'll put a mask on in a
store that asks because i'm not a douche
bag i hate when people like wig out i
just don't go in there
yeah i will go to this dad
i get but i've been in a store where
they offered me the mask and i was like
i really want this thing i'm like here
you're protected
whatever like i'm gonna buy this if the
store is like the only one we have to go
there so we were buying computer parts
and we wanted to get like the latest
graphics card or whatever and it's the
only place we can get it on the spot i
was like whatever
but there's there's coffee shops out
here and a local coffee shop had a big
sign saying wear your mask half the
people weren't but i was like starbucks
was literally 100 feet away so we went
to starbucks instead thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you